if you tell your mom that I'm going to
take the blood pressure and the
temperature coming up for 90 and with a
broken collarbone gourdev would once
have been admitted to hospital
potentially for weeks but clinicians
have come to her home keeping her off
the ward and her family are happy to
help if we can manage some of the sort
of minor ailments as we say that they
are sometimes if they're managed better
at home it spares beds and the nursing
staff
to tend to those who are more sick and
in need of Greater care that's more
important now than ever was first nurses
then paramedics on strike on top of
normal winter pressures hospitals need
to keep every possible bed free for
Urgent Care although tomorrow is is very
important for us to work harder to help
our colleagues which are not happy and
they try to show that they are not happy
we can cover and we can help the
patients to keep them in in the
community in their home and provide the
care that they needed the clay ponds
Rehabilitation Unit in West London is
also taking in as many patients as
possible from acute hospitals there are
73 beds but coveted and flu mean two
can't be used almost every bed in the
hospital is now full and they're
expecting more patients to be admitted
in the coming hours but they are hoping
to discharge a four or five home just to
make way for another wave tomorrow one
two three Bernard had an operation on
his spine several weeks ago and has been
moved from hospital to hospital as he
slowly recovers he's seen how hard staff
are working on the wards they are
vast busy
overwhelmed every day
I don't know how this the nurses stand
it
nurses here aren't striking but support
those who are action elsewhere quickly
ripples through the system that simply
isn't any spare capacity in the NHS
there is a layering of winter pressures
the the planning for a long bank holiday
weekend the
um the pressure of covid the pressure of
influenza other pressures in the system
and the industrial action on top is is
clearly an incredibly challenging time
for all of us what we're what we're
trying to do is is make sure that we are
as fully staffed as we can be but we've
got the pathways working as smoothly as
they can be the NHS has never been
running this hot for this long the
current crisis follows two years of
covid and it is community services that
are stepping up to ease some of the
pressure Thomas Moore Sky News in West
London